champion olympique de cuisine c'est
ainsi que l'on peut appeler aujourd'hui
Thibault Ruggieri chef adjoint de la
création salée chez Lenôtre à plaisir
qui vient de décrocher le Bocuse d'Or
c'était ce mercredi soir à Lyon et ce
jeudi matin au téléphone la voix un peu
éraillée par la nuit qui vient de passer
et que l'on devine longue Thibault
Ruggieri savoure son prix
on achète avec tous les compatriotes et
tous les candidats et tous ceux qui ont
cru et qui nous ont supportés depuis
hier 18h c'est des photos des interviews
c'est autre chose mais ça fait partie du
deal donc une immense joie une immense
fierté
sachant qu'il y avait une grosse
responsabilité de leur présenter la
France donc vraiment extrêmement content
et énormément d'émotions pour pour moi
et toute l'équipe qui était de chez Le
Nôtre avec qui j'ai chez les plats qui
m'ont c'est des lits de manière
exceptionnelle cette compétition du
Bocuse d'Or existe depuis 1987 elle
réunit tous les deux ans 24 chefs du
monde entier Thibault rugiri a remporté
ce prix sous les yeux de son coach
Fabrice Rochasson le jeune homme a
découvert la cuisine à l'âge de 11 ans
en inventant comme il l'a appelé son
gâteau poubelle une sorte de 4/4 une
inventivité aux apparences toutes
simples qu'il a donc mené aujourd'hui au
sommet le dernier Bocuse d'Or pour la
France remonte à 2007